We often use extrinsic rewards not only in the workplace, but also in our daily
life. We see that extrinsic rewards can be used outside of the workplace as
well, for example, we can use extrinsic rewards to get children to brush their
teeth, do their homework, or even make their bed. This is no different than
employers using rewards to increase worker productivity as well as accuracy.
Although extrinsic rewards have been shown to be effective in the workplace,
there are some circumstances where extrinsic rewards can have the opposite
effect. How does this work? Let's say that you enjoy cooking, and you do so
often. You're always trying out new recipes. If your mom starts to pay you for
cooking, it turns out that you may start to cook in order to get paid. Rather
than for pleasure. So what was once intrinsic enjoyment, your cooking, is no
longer so because it has been rewarded by an external source, which is money.